alright hey what's going on it's bill
burr and it's time for the Monday
morning podcast for Monday July 1st 2019
oh my god where is this dumber going I
am here with we always wonder he always
wonderful the always lovely Justin Long
who does arguably the most favorite
character on f is for family Kevin
Murphy hey before it before we get into
that and I and I put you on the spot
dildo yeah this is surreal for me
because I listen I listen to almost
every episode and I you are you are a
big fan of I'm gonna try to tone it down
a little bit on one come on
no no it's alright but I'm a big fan so
it's weird to hear you even go
go ahead Wow go to the Monday morning
but it's weird to even hear you do the
introduction yeah that's why I don't
video it oh I like to keep a mystery
yeah I just got like share where is she
that's right she's in Malibu be like
well going in bed with shares and I saw
the you know behind the shares still hot
share was [ __ ] smoking when I was a
kid I got you babe hey let me yeah let
me read this here please let the
listeners okay I did a live podcast from
Phoenix Arizona in front of a crowd no
edits will be posted on my youtube
channel this week
please subscribe to the Monday morning
podcast on the YouTube page and you can
follow at the mm podcast and at bill
burr on Twitter for tour updates and new
videos I got a couple of new tour dates
here would be at Foxwoods Resort and
Casino in Connecticut on August 11th and
I'll be doing the cosmopolitan in Las
Vegas on December 21st Justin I'm
actually going there in September to do
a date because I want to see Elton John
because I believe him when he says he's
going to retire oh is that what he says
I think this is the last one it's
getting that for a while I know
everybody else says it all the time yeah
everybody always thinks oh well there
they go this is the last one
this is there anybody a bar of
singer-songwriters yeah like I saw the
who in 89 like seven years after their
first farewell
and I paid to see them because there was
like dude you don't know you don't know
if these guys gonna be back and I'd like
to see the stones cuz it's also just a
fact of Nate they might they might not I
mean they might somebody might die I
mean how old are they they're pushing
like 80 right
they're all there yeah you want to I was
really hard eighty like that's like an
old 80 Keith Richards Heath is it but
Keith doesn't go as hard as everybody
thinks Keith went hard in the 70s and
then that was it he got labeled is that
guy like I don't think it smokes a lot
though he smokes and I don't know I
don't know what else he has like a glass
of wine or whatever but I don't he
doesn't like you physically can't
[ __ ] do it you can't do it yeah you
get to it I hate that I've gotten to
that age like my new drug now is eight
hours sleep it's my favorite thing oh my
god well that's why I got a physical the
other day but my doctor said can't wait
where's all your mother's my dad's I'm
41 now and so I fell you 41 you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you look like a 22 a flat
stomach full head of hair oh my I think
you're like 31 you get a flat stomach no
I don't you see you shape your head and
why do you think that is justice because
I have beautiful locks well I don't the
last time you tried to grow it in I'm
wondering how much it could grow I got
that I got the thing in the back it's
thin in the back and I don't know what
else at some point you just got to take
control of it
I think Travolta Travolta Travolta did
that recently he finally did I think he
just started I think he did
I can't a matter of two pays like how
hot your [ __ ] head gets actually not
like a day like this can you imagine
I've seen I've seen a couple bill and I
were just walking we were waiting
through how would you even what you say
I want to describe around the humanity
out there we are [ __ ] idiots we are
like right in the crosshairs of the gay
pride parade we were supposed to meet on
Friday something happened when you
weren't gonna get here in time cells I
called my boss I took a bus from the
Berkshires in Massachusetts and I
figured oh when the bus will arrive
roughly around the time it says it will
and we're supposed to get it at 2:30
right 2:25 and it got in it 505 mm-hmm
that's what time either buster oh my god
in that nuts stuck in traffic
what
that's why I don't take buses anymore
yeah well I should have known if it was
like a booze one you could like drink
well I don't drink anymore
but anyways yes so we [ __ ] down here
right in the middle of the gay pride
parade I was joking with you like when
I'm home on my couch in air-conditioning
I am the most liberal person ever
you get me out in the [ __ ] Sun and I
was literally like these these people
are against God because you can't
Malaysia I'll be eliminated
now is sure in hell know what it was it
wasn't all the gay people it was all the
cops not knowing where they could tell
you to cross exactly and the and the ala
the quote-unquote the people who are
doing it for the day who are buying the
rainbow flower the ally twenty dollars
from the banners it's all become so
weirdly monetized
and look there's no I was saying to you
there's nobody I like more than I think
maybe my favorite demographic are gay
people I love I think I prefer them to
straight alight the gays I like the I
like cigar smokers cigar smoking gays
your cigar smoker any I don't give a
[ __ ] I don't want you out cigar smokers
are cool they're chillin it's quiet its
smoky but it's [ __ ] quiet and they're
all like characters and like Scorsese
character they're sort of like I don't
know there's just something about it
where you're you're an old man in a cool
way
you know what it is maybe there's an
ease to them there's a patience to them
because yeah you got to be patient to
smoke one of those you don't help them
down right I think when you're early on
you don't know what you're doing like I
had a buddy of mine I give Mike a Cuban
cigar and he would tell me later he
smoked it like right outside the comedy
club it's like you know near the
dumpster that's what you did it it's
like smoking a cigar is an event you sit
down you chill nice chair
there's a game on you have a nice drink
right and then the conversation because
because this cigar because the thing
that that's holding you there okay is so
enjoyable versus that parade which was a
total inhibiting what the [ __ ] we were
trying to do like if I was sitting on on
a on a balcony watching that parade I
would have the time of my [ __ ] life
so we're saying we should get drinks out
there just yeah trying to get through it
yeah this is a completely different way
because they don't
let you go east-west all these streets
are shut down right so every street I go
to there's none there's a barrier and he
and I was also thinking the amount of
money they must be spending the money
that the city must be spending on cops
on the [ __ ] barriers yeah there's like
there's three major but this is also
it's it's the way they were billing it
was this is sort of the world's pride
parades okay so that's what it is this
is like the Super Bowl of gays and week
we came in like the non-sports fans who
also happen to go to New Orleans because
they wanted to try the [ __ ] fried
chicken or something down there oh go
down to Bourbon Street there's a bunch
of meathead sport with we like foodies
who heard about one particular
restaurant on Bourbon Street
yeah we're doing a Travel Show no I'll
tell you what's what's be talking about
sports and [ __ ] is is gay is that polite
Pride Parade is that is not the gayest
thing that's going on right now I
actually argue the game okay is thing
right now that's going on is the NBA
offseason yeah they should have like a
flamboyant like slight I'm talking like
80s sitcom level gay guy reading the off
season like did you hear that Kyrie is
talking to KD on a boat and they're all
gonna end up in New York honey that's
the rumor don't hold me to it
it's so [ __ ] gay it's written crest I
can't if I was running Major League
Baseball I'd be like how the [ __ ] do we
compete with this yeah there's all of
this [ __ ] they're all getting together
and they're talking and they're on and
Anthony are finally back together
can't wait to pass the ball underneath
to Anthony Davis it's sure there's a lot
of drama there's a lot of bitching and
it's funny the first day it all started
with Kobe and the [ __ ] Lakers they
started they started this [ __ ] I
never remember this when I was a kid I
was such a big basketball fan growing up
I don't remember it's the pylon team
they did it they got shacked and they
got Phil Jackson and and you know and
then he then in Kobe his whole career
demanded like a fresh he was like an
emperor every three years yeah bring you
to bring a fresh new batch of [ __ ]
free agents in so then they would just
win a championship after champion
chips and then the Celtics did it we did
it in 2008 with the big three yeah well
the one led the Raptors one and then
Miami did it and then everyone's trying
to do now ten Golden's Golden State they
uh they did it with KD KD piled on but
like they also their their weird hybrid
whether it was an incredible draft with
Steph and clay and all of those guys
they all got drafted in the yes as far
as I know I'm a little out of my element
here with the MV but as far as I know
those guys all became stars there wasn't
like they they made their bones
somewhere else and then you know went
cashed in and went out there then they
became a juggernaut and in in the middle
of all of that was the Spurs that just
did it the old-school way uh passing the
ball yeah like I think the greatest
player of that era wasn't Kobe we like
Tim Duncan yeah but everybody would but
he wasn't it wasn't flashy he was just
such a yeah down and did the job he was
going glass what did they call him he
was beating you like your dad your dad
would [ __ ] beat you with that
turnaround off the glass and silently it
must be so frustrating
he wouldn't yeah when he retired he just
retired yeah you know you don't make a
documentary and win an Oscar he just saw
that he just sort of left Neil brands
got a great line about Kawhi Leonard who
reminds me a little bit of that I mean
that mentality you know Neil Brendan's
gotta learn about qilin
where he does he said Kawhi Leonard
seems like his he's the kind of guy
whose family doesn't even know he plays
in the NBA he just like he's just like I
had him going out to work and a couple
hours later he comes home and he's like
what's for dinner that's why he's so
badass and I that's what and everybody
on Instagram go I'm acting like he's a
robot and he doesn't have any feelings
it's like no okay he could ramp it up
but the rest of you could dial it down
yeah cuz I gotta tell you that [ __ ]
[ __ ] in sports now where anytime you
do anything you turn you look at the
crowd and yell out like you're in 300 I
love and you're yelling at a dad who's
there with this four year old ID and
then of course if you don't catch the
pass or you strike out or you [ __ ]
don't hit the layup then you just sort
of just go to the dugout to go back
there's no grandstanding yeah but then
they get mad at that pitchers stroke
what was the pitcher for the he got
almost got in a fight with tweed
tonight I love that guy cuz that he's
calling he called Puig outgoing what are
you doin over just yelling yeah I'm not
doing anything and he's big for a
pitcher yeah I mean he's like it could
have been a good night and the
announcers were like come on you you you
got close to the mound you know you
could have made it there yeah you know
he always does it he starts to go then
people hold them back and Annie really
starts charging that's got how that's
how I fight too that's why I recognize
it's like oh he's doing that oh he's
afraid yeah hold me back please help me
back you hold me back you got a good
grip are you gonna let me Adam well
let's try that start I feel like this is
more I'm on Bryant I feel kind of bad
for your listeners now because as one of
your loyal listeners when you do do
interviews I always miss I'd like them
but I missed when it's just you ripping
and I feel like this is you you don't
want to stay out of the way there's a
couple of oh maybe it said I'm not a
good interviewer you like that and I
forced you into a corner now you have to
compliment me or just stick with the
insults
double down baby no I know you all right
I just I here's what it is
I enjoy just you so much you ripping
which like to do that every twice a week
is crazy no great I get to empty out my
[ __ ] head yeah I get to empty it out
say what I want to [ __ ] go off on
who's I was pushing my lovely daughter
down the street and the gays were
getting all ramped up for the parade
right they were it's just like what you
wanted to sell in this past month was
tank tops you would have [ __ ] made a
killing right god
so all these shredded gay guys are
walking down the street and then there's
this lesbian chick with their girlfriend
she's out there just no shirt on no bra
tits painted with like glitter on it and
I got my kid there and it's just like
you know that's insane it's that good
nudity no yeah I feel bad for all the
conservative gays whatever that happens
I always pictured them the roller
rolling their eyes just being like see
this said why there's a breeder with his
kid and he's going to leave with that
story I'm sitting here acting like a
gentleman with my tank top
tucked into my short shorts behaving
myself my khakis short shorts and my
salmon cutoff I was worried that there
was gonna be a lot more lewd behavior
it's it's not it's way way way toned but
I think also feel married to LA yeah an
LA was the Halloween parade somebody
talked me into going to that in the late
90s this older gentleman I met in a bus
station it gave me a drink
I got roofied and we went down there
dude and the Halloween parade out there
yeah that that is not there anybody
under the age of 28 it was just they
were over the age of 30 late 90s it was
just like all I remember there's just a
float of dicks yeah and it was just I uh
I I confused it with the gay pride
parade it's like why would they do that
if they're trying to get mainstream and
then it didn't take it took me years
because we're so like culture shock I'd
never been around that yeah it's so it's
true and it's really great I remember
the first time I went to LA was to do
this movie my first the first movie I
ever got the first time second time had
been on a plane there all these new
experiences for me it was in 99 and they
put me up at a hotel code Lamont Rose on
Hammond right off the sunset also
between sunset and Santa Monica
Boulevard there's that steep decline and
that hit that you and so on my time up I
didn't have a car or anything on my time
up I'd just walk and naturally just
walked downhill and it's and it empties
out right into the heart of West
Hollywood you know I'm right there and
and I remember talking to my friends
back home they were like has LA how's it
going out there and I was like it's good
people are great you know it's been the
guys are really friendly it's super gay
it's so gay like it's wrong you didn't
know that you are in tribal dance all
day every restaurant I've been to I just
walked in that neighborhood and it's a
purse few days I was there but it really
like for somebody coming from the
suburbs or and I went to a very
progressive college I went to Vassar
which was like we had a dance isn't that
a woman's car it was yeah look at you
yeah I showed up and you crushed it all
then yes it was 62 percent female did
you used to say progressive [ __ ] when
you were banging all of them it was
before I've never respected you
much did you let him be on top so they
could feel like they were in the power
position and there were a lot of a lot
of the guys of the other 30% that were
get guys they were gay so it was it was
the first time I had really been around
that it was really don't you crushed it
it was fun he majored in [ __ ] look what
it really raised the bar was difficult
then to get out of the real world what
is the what is it what is the area of
expertise at Vassar as far as like
engineering school and is it there it's
you know they have a really good English
department went I was a philosophy major
I dropped out after two years you just
went then you banged a bunch of chicks I
went and I really fell in love that what
was your opening line I'm not gay I'm
listening yeah but also track the I was
in a sketch comedy group it was the
[ __ ] best it was the opposite of what
my high school experience was like which
was like typical suburban you know the
jocks and the rich kids were on top
right and then like theater nerds were
closer to the bottom and it was totally
reversed at that bastard to the point I
was cool about my high school was my
grades specifically everybody hung out
with everybody by the end oh yeah yeah
it was a public school yeah it was just
like by the end no [ __ ] it just that
what happened was it was weird like the
grade above me and the grade below me
were like Mad Max they were like
lunatics like the grade below is could
kick the [ __ ] out of our grade right and
the great above us would they were
[ __ ] lunatics like there was one kid
in that grade like his party trick was
he would eat a lightbulb
loonatics Oh Luna to host crunch it and
you saw he did bloody I know it's odd I
didn't go anywhere near that guy gonna
show up with my [ __ ] orange hair and
he's eating a light boil and but that
would be the next thing on the [ __ ]
menu for entertainment I didn't go
yourself how do you go from light but
where do you go after light bulbs might
tell you where you might go is what my
brother's gonna be pissed for telling
this my brother loves you too he got
he's the one that got me into your
podcast but he he went to school with
the kid and I think he may have
witnessed this the kid was like and it
was something dumb the kid was like if
you make that some other kid crumpled up
a piece of paper
all right who thinks I can't make this
shot you know from across the thing he
goes uh he goes and the kid volunteered
he goes if you make that I'll eat my own
poo I'll eat my [ __ ] anything that kid
made it
and according to my brother no when
there were wit many witnesses it was in
the cafeteria he dropped his pants he
wanted to do it probably he wanted to do
and he willed it he willed that thing in
there and it wasn't even like a little
bit was like oh okay yeah sorry you can
cut that out I asked you if you cut
anything your Helen I'm not leaving I'm
a cut net at all Oh [ __ ] leaving that
in I deserve it for Jesus all right yeah
yeah and every once in a while my
brother will get it I said that he
wanted to do that he must have right it
happened that's something that happened
in school that I went to yeah and I
suppose this person you so we have to
gradually do here there you know I
haven't been in in the recorded with you
in a couple of season now and one of my
favorite memories was trying to hold it
together when you were doing Kevin you
know when you do that I wasn't doing
anything huh sure and you just had that
look on your face of like adolescents
but also like I don't thinking you're
making a point but you weren't like the
first time I watch you and you basically
had that character like day one well
Vince was telling me I got this guy
Justin long I'm Tony he can do this
[ __ ] thing and then just for God I
listen to him he's wrong so yeah you got
a lot of you guys I love it
you should know this guy and you [ __ ]
just immediately went in there and just
had like that that you had your eyebrows
down [ __ ] you oh yeah why I think that
guy dildo it lives in me he lives in
that I think he's like in people that
it's that it's the adolescent it's the
kid I don't think that effort goes where
you just learn to manage it a little bit
I mean how do you how do you like like
um it's always fascinated with actors
how you guys do this [ __ ] as far as like
actually becoming like somebody else
because this is like there's like the
there's two kinds of acting there's just
like I'll tell you about Adam driver yes
yeah
driver I love that yeah and a driver she
knows her have you seen him and burn
this dynasty Dodie
I'm not you know I love that play
everybody's great not but that [ __ ]
guy comes in and he's just a tour de
force it just comes in and he's killing
and his comedic timing there's so much
[ __ ] in there that isn't necessarily
written funny that he gets a huge laugh
on and it's the way he says it when he
says it and he's got a little thing he
does the way he folds his pants the way
he meticulously takes his time he says
so different than you do yes totally
different different accent and all of
that and the wait he's kind of turned in
his head this way the way he was talking
and it was just like that that's it
that's a guy that like you know I'm just
excited after after doing a couple years
here this cartoon that I can give you
three different reads of a line that's
my Daniel day-lewis yeah but I got about
where you going where are you going
where are you going where are you going
there you go you got for it better than
me I got a bone to pick with you because
you you you talk about not being at that
level
I saw the front-runner recently I don't
know if I texted you about this you're
[ __ ] great you're like that was me
with a fake mustache really you remind
me like Joe Pantoliano or like like
bruno kirby back in the day I just
brought him up the other day I love that
I love that guy and it's honest and it
and and you talked about this without in
the context of Adam driver but it is
[ __ ] hard to go in and be yourself -
it's hard to be a guy close to you and
that's what you do that's what you were
doing seemingly in the front-runner and
it's natural it's honest it it's that's
not easy to do so i think mike you
should give yourself a little more
credit little more credit but yeah that
day was fun when we were yelling at each
a there's no one better
no you Sam Rockwell's Koechner you
should seek Ackerman Koechner does Bob
Pogo well he looks like he's doing the
backstroke he's swimming his arms it
just swims his arms backwards oh we can
we film him every year when he does it
and it's just like yeah you want to be
in like it's just like is Koechner
coming in detective comes well I
remember one day I think you may have
told me this or maybe prize Mike Price
told me who exactly
when to put on I was recording after
someone had been in there and I put the
headphones on and it was they were so
soft like the ones we're wearing now
he's kinda happy once they were so soggy
that it left a like a liquid rim oh no
no and they said I said what the [ __ ] is
this and and they said oh that's um
Hector was just in you if they bring out
the headphones but I bet because he's so
physically so I mean you in it and it
sounds like that that's why the
performance is so good he's [ __ ]
great yeah
my favorite day I think on that thing
was that time I came to New York and
both you and Sam we all got to record
with each other that day and I got to
watch you two guys [ __ ] around and Sam's
crazy like Sam doesn't even wanted to
partition between you yeah he wants to
be like in the booth mm-hmm with you and
yeah I've got I can't believe like all
the different levels of like thrills
I've gotten out of that show like one of
my favorite [ __ ] things is when we
write a line and one of the actors tries
to deliver and it makes him laugh that's
I never thought I would get off on that
because I always thought like I'm a
comedian I want to be the guy saying the
funny line but I totally get a rush out
of that was my line or or looking at the
writer you know at the table read who
came up with it I always give them a
[ __ ] look it's just like interesting
yeah you ever think about writing a
whole script maybe something for you to
story um yes and no cuz I got the kid
now and I have to I gotta be honest with
you that I really see like however long
this cartoon lasts when it ends like I I
don't I'm not filling that void up with
more work I'm filling it up with more my
kid so you prefer doing I mean stand-up
is still going to you that you don't
know - last night last night I did a gig
for W DVE
Randy Bauman he's been putting me on
like he's one of like they used to be a
guy like that in every town in Clear
Channel just [ __ ] eviscerated all of
them and he survived and this guy like
Pittsburgh was a hard ticket to sell and
where the Improv was was in this this
[ __ ] mall and there was one way in
and one way out and it was just a [ __ ]
show
so you and it was a big 400 seater and
it was just like in pot it was just so
[ __ ] hard so and I got to know him
and on the rich [ __ ] tour Charlie
Murphy rest his soul and donnell
rawlings who was in Pittsburgh when I
was there and Randi Bauman's like a
promoter he's like oh he sees the
Pittsburgh ion the Pittsburgh Steelers
Pittsburgh Penguins papers by radio
network okay okay so like yeah if you
live there that would be the morning
drive that you like yes absolutely so he
um you know he told me like I would have
a Thursday through Sunday there and I
wouldn't be drawn fly so he goes to the
next time you come he goes call in
during the year when the Bruins played
the Penguins or the Patriots play the
Steelers you know if there's aa really
yeah oh god yeah I still haven't gotten
over that I can't I haven't gotten over
the fact I'm fine with the Blues winning
it I haven't gotten over the fact I that
officiate he's gonna bug me for a while
like that they let him fight in the
playoffs and they they that they let him
play that way the way they haven't let
people play and then we would we had
like it brought a knife to a gunfight
like we got we got the [ __ ] kicked out
of us was team getting out Bruin [ __ ]
must be really frustrated it was really
frustrated you know it's Ari but but the
other side is though the other side is
the style of hockey that st. Louis
played I like you want that consistent I
would like it to come back yeah because
everybody all of these [ __ ] [ __ ]
watched Olympic hockey like there's no
fighting that's the kind of hockey I
would watch and the NHL always zigs when
they should zag they listen to that [ __ ]
I well I will tell you this as
frustrating as that is and by the way
last night when I was in the place where
we performed was where the Penguins play
okay they they had they sold the arena
right and I was in my dressing room and
they when I went in there they had Game
seven of the Bruins st. Louis and it was
it was tune enough in st. Louis and in
my head I thought Mario Lemieux made
sure they did that because he's a
ballbreaker I did a couple things for
him I was like is this guy still busting
my chops no no no they said it didn't
come from him but they definitely said
that they were gonna tell him so he
could laugh at me cuz but you also get
Pittsburgh respect I mean you like my
favorite sound ever and I thought
I got like I got like amped up when I
went up to that venue and I saw they
have their five I mean they had the real
banners inside but they hang them
outside like five like the Stanley Cup
things that I just thinking like they
didn't have [ __ ] yeah
like when I was a kid they didn't have
one and they've they've won five since
91 I think like that is really [ __ ]
impressive pretty cool and the fact that
they got Lemieux and Jaeger and then
they went away and then they had they
had a dip and then they got crossed me
in Moulton and that's really hard to do
and Europe you're [ __ ] great
franchise if you if you can do that
because I don't know who owned the
Penguins before them you started running
[ __ ] but like to transition the way they
did like say like the Patriots like Bill
Belichick's almost 70 Tom Brady's you
know who knows when he's gonna quit but
I mean it's it's towards the end when
those two guys leaving Bob Kraft is no
spring check is true when that all goes
away
that's true like the obvious happens but
for the obvious not to happen it's very
rare that you go from were they great to
from all the greats leaving and then
more greats come that quickly like if
you look at the Miami Dolphins where
they went from Bob Griese I was bring
this point out to Dan Marino then Dan
Marino left in 99 they're still waiting
that's right and they've signed free
agents and they you know they got that
kid from the Jets they got that good hot
look Chad Pennington Jay Cutler they
they've gone through [ __ ] everybody
they just haven't been able to find a
guy that's right yeah and you can do
what the cults do and see a guy you want
and then just tank a [ __ ] season yeah
Jim Irsay one of the biggest cheats in
the [ __ ] business he cheats so much
he like he points it it's like the
[ __ ] dude that's like a frat boy date
rapist with the me too but none that
that's he's the football version of that
yeah I I didn't mean to go on a tangent
but there was a but you know what I was
gonna say something about hawk I know
nothing about how I know I only know
about hockey through your show and it's
just and for whatever reason I didn't
grow up with it it's a sport that does
not interest me but I still
this I still love hearing you talk about
I wonder how many other listeners are
like that I don't know because I told me
it's the greatest sport even though I'm
still walking on that that that that
crushing loss but like but they don't
see us anymore they don't even they know
they don't show the fights and they
don't fight this what [ __ ] kills me
is the way st. Louis was playing was why
you have an enforcer and they would come
out there and they'd beat the [ __ ] out
of somebody or run their goaltender yeah
like I can't do right I really can't
keep the divorce is too too soon all
right so our sorry I brought it up
but Randy bellman you were saying Randy
Bauman brings you out there oh yeah so
Randy has been bringing me out there
forever and so last night you know he
had us all come out there like it was
just like his it was Jessica Carson Ian
bagg Billy Gardell I always hope I'm
gonna [ __ ] forget somebody though
Caldwell Brandi Bauman who else who else
I'm gonna remember on the walk home and
yes it's just a disorient so we went up
there and we just and you were asking
about like how much fun it is yeah and I
was sitting there going like I have not
done a lot of time because I've been
doing this stupid you know acting thing
right that's stupid I just felt dumb
saying I've been in a movie yeah so I've
been doing like spots and [ __ ] but not
like hitting it hard and all of a sudden
I got to do like this this arena and and
you know I thought okay we're all gonna
do 20s and they had me going [ __ ]
last so I got to follow all of these
beasts everybody [ __ ] murdered right
and then I was just sitting there like
what do I talk about when I go up there
and I just I just decided like don't you
know don't put any pressure on you and
it went up there and a [ __ ] went
great and I just felt like it's just
this just nothing yeah and then I was
doing my abortion bit and as always as
always someone that way to your sound
white lady just goes in their 20s it
just ceased like next move on move on no
no yeah I hate that one
she was cool cuz I made fun of her and
then she was she was cool then she was
also there with the date so I made a
whole big joke going like and I'm being
cool with you and I go not because of
you it's because of the guy you're with
and I'm I'm a [ __ ] wingman I want him
to have a good ride home any [ __ ]
gate you know I don't be a cock-blocker
yeah well I don't want him to hurt you
know he's got his [ __ ] sit there
listen you're full of [ __ ] cuz of what I
said even though she brought the whole
thing on well I was asking you about
that earlier it's but it is like how
would why would people go into your show
they know your sensibility they know but
but this is different right because it's
like a bunch of comedians there was a
bunch of they were still cool like it's
it's more um it's more if I go to do
like a guest spot hmm like then and then
I kinda have to understand that but it's
it's also like a its it's like a it's a
fun [ __ ] situation it's never like a
bad thing that has never derailed a show
like have you tried a heckler so bad one
of these these people but you know about
the abortion bit let's say who is who's
throwing you off so much that it's it's
changed the course of a show for you oh
[ __ ] yeah
at the beginning you you would Roy Wood
jr. just got it sorry bill yes they all
got like kind of a vacant look on his
face for the last this is bugging me and
I felt like I needed to kind of stall
and filibuster right because I knew you
were just trying to remember trying to
remember so you're an actor you can read
you read people but you know yelling at
one another not to jump back to that it
was so fun for me it's so fun for me to
do those scenes with you bill plays my
dad on the show and and rank Frank
Murphy and there's no one better at
yelling there's no one better at like
expressing range I know it's
embarrassing dude my anger is
embarrassing to me at this point well
you've been working on a lot I have but
I haven't been going to therapy because
I don't want to do that [ __ ] over the
phone it's just [ __ ] weird like I'm
Gordon and a pizza and I'm talking about
my [ __ ] feelings for in person in
person and I prefer a woman oh I don't
like [ __ ] sitting there talking to
another guy like that intimate weird
[ __ ] just gets [ __ ] weird
well because eventually it beers into it
could be sexual or it could be R like
childhood stuff and it's you know you
don't want to yeah you get like choked
up and sitting there was some guy it's
just it's too you know can weird but I
don't want to reach that level of
comfort yeah another straight guy I just
died you can call it homophobic I don't
give a [ __ ] okay this is my therapy
session I'm living my truth this is what
I'm comfortable with that's that makes
sense
yeah I do yeah are you do you cry easily
do you do you like if you're around your
wife or your daughter you must have
really moving moments I mean you talk
[Music]
animals suffering children suffering I'm
kind of hack I'm a hacky crier
and people dying yeah like I got a
friend of mine that's gonna go soon and
then I had to go I'm gonna say goodbye
to mrs. [ __ ] brutal yeah it's just
[ __ ] brutal so well it's like the
important I mean that's that's like but
like I'm not like but like when my wife
would watch The Biggest Loser and those
those fatties would start crying like I
would just die I would die laughing
I would die laughing and my wife would
get so mad at me she goes this show is
inspirational what's wrong with you it's
like it's a guy crying over sandwiches
this is just funny right and then what
was hilarious was when she came to my
house one time and she was totally into
the show so it was like the finale and
there was these two brothers who I don't
know what happened to them but the more
they lost the weight the more
emotionally God and it literally got to
the point where like the guy would reach
over and turn on a lamp and just start
crying like six weeks ago I couldn't do
that my armpit fat would have blocked me
I couldn't even see the switch right so
angers were to chub yeah exactly I
couldn't I didn't know there was a light
in the room I was blocking it all out
with my lard so we're watching it at
home cuz Nia wanted to watch it and one
of those [ __ ] dudes got up there and
started crying and I started laughing
and my wife elbowed me I was laughing
quietly because I didn't want to Barris
my wife or whatever and then my mother
walked in the room and saw the guy
crying and she goes oh my god she goes
come on get it together get it together
and then my wife
sigh she's just like mrs. Byrne well it
must have been like apple doesn't fall
far from the from Bob from the tree over
there
my mother's [ __ ] hilarious I can I
could I met her monthly I can't oh now
she is like yeah yeah she does like my
mother is is like totally uh like she
holds you responsible for your actions
and I mean that what is the biggest
compliment well okay the way people
raise kids now yeah where what is your
feelings what is wrong talk to me but
blah blah blah or if you fall down it's
always like hugs and everything and my
mother would just be it well you
shouldn't have done that
what is he's running what did you think
was gonna happen
use your [ __ ] hands yeah that was
literally that's funny it was just like
you know well you idiot you should have
been riding your bike out in the street
consequences yet I think then always be
like a tinge of anger and I think that
that was the love that she didn't know
how to express huh
she didn't had a hug she said now she's
she's the exact like but but what I love
about it is it's it's made me who I am
in a great way yeah but if he cuz we
also made you appreciate the huggers in
your life the people who are able to
show affection and it depends it depends
because some huggers are just [ __ ]
gross they're just yes people sure
there's a lot of people you don't want a
hug most of the people we passed on the
way here
it was just sweating and glittery gross
hairy and yeah lardy jiggly a lot of
jiggling yeah jiggling high energy yeah
I mean I was just a grumpy old man and
it's so [ __ ] how we have to impress
upon people how like oppressively hot it
is to that's a part of it I guess I mean
if we're like kind of brisk in a nice
weather now do you think that that that
is why they have the Gay Pride now or is
that people not liking gays and they
make a march in this really hot weather
over the gays like we're not wearing
clothes
anyways honey I don't any excuse well we
had a dance at that basser which I keep
told it called the homo hop that was
like the big dance at my college isn't
called the homo ha they're crazy and
this is in 90 that late 90s all right oh
yeah so that's I mean
kind of ahead of its time believe it or
not that was a long that was a long time
forget about the time that was socially
a long time ago mm-hmm this guy who is
doing though that was like centuries ago
yeah who did the office one of the most
absurd shows ever yeah am I totally
absurd borderline could get cartoonish
towards the end can't do it anymore
guess what he said yeah he goes you
could not do that show it's and I was
trying to think what in the [ __ ]
oh dude watch Seinfeld every Seinfeld
episode Britney watching now knowing
what you know about writing TV shows you
like the brilliance of the structure of
those episodes it's fun it's a I marvel
at how that shows written right and so
much of it you can't do so many episodes
there's always something that comes up
at one point like wow I can't do that
anymore and people well they were the
anti progressive they were all about
themselves that's what I loved about I
thought the you know what I loved it
they were so selfishly about their own
needs but it wasn't malicious but then
in the end well they always do bite him
in the ass but in the end then they
gonna put on trial by all the characters
everything I love the last episode I
mean that's coming around
facebait people are gonna go back and
watch the last episode that I think they
got too freaked out that they took him
out of New York but I I loved it was
when they lost Larry David I mean it's
something that show lost something when
but but I
that's annex over waiting for Guffman
the show like waiting for Guffman she's
doing that voice just that Corky
Severson waiting for Guffman Corky
Sinclair I'm sorry and you'll love it
there's so many you know what I saw
yesterday that I really [ __ ] like
Jeff see Lee Marvin in Point Blank No
third if they did well did you ever see
Tim Robbins in there's a movie oh yeah
that the play but not the player know
the Jesus Christ I always always uses as
a reference about Hollywood now the one
ways the Vietnam vet and he gets shot
Jacob's Ladder Jacob's Ladder this stays
so this is Jacob's Ladder before Jacob's
Ladder okay were you're watching it
going like was this all the dream or
whatever and it's just like Lee Marvin
some of those movies in the seventies
you see them they're like that when it
comes to like I mean we parody it on f
is for family you guys are really really
funny about parody
with Nesta like slap women I mean it was
like it was borderline abusive it was
like those guys were like oh you talk
about oh yeah culturally different
that's why I liked watching uh like me
TV did something I I had you know
everybody had like a reaction to this
this whole like political divide
screaming and yelling at each other and
people went down the rabbit hole yeah on
either side and became went like further
more further extreme or you just sort of
tapped out I tapped out and I just went
the rabbit hole I went down was like me
TV and I just started watching all of
these old TV shows and all of these old
movies the best that took me back to
like when I was a kid and I used to
watch him with my parents
we'd make popcorn and we thought it was
amazing that we had beanbags and we had
a we didn't have a color TV we know a
color TV till I was like 10 yeah we
hadn't got one pretty late wit but we
had like a 13-inch TV for the first 10
11 years of my life but it's so f is for
family parodies that but it's also it's
also looks like kind of fondly on it
there's something about that's why I
like yeah that there's something about
that show where it's like yeah that's
funny and like they were kind of manure
things quote-unquote properly but there
was something beautiful about the
simplicity of it all you know yeah I I
don't know something happened to me man
I've been doing that I got back into
reading oh really but I got to read I'm
not a T do you know what I just say
blurs new I just read oh my god when I'm
done with that you got to read that
thing [ __ ] you want to talk about if you
tried to make a movie out of that
[ __ ] book just the first chapter
where he just talked about all the women
they bang let's say 'christopher
plumbers book about acting it's like it
might as well be called like here's who
I slept with oh yeah it's a lot of like
and then I bet it'd so-and-so and then I
did Henry the fifth and I hate how [ __ ]
can be out that long and now any [ __ ]
[ __ ] now when they want to put
themselves up on a pedestal can then go
back and look at something like that and
then just be like system oh nice yeah
yeah and it's just like no what they're
showing you is what you would be like
if you if you were born during his
generation yeah somehow everybody in
2019 can look back like John Wayne was
my favorite one that they attempt the
guy's been dead for 40 years that they
come out yeah and he was born in 1907
and they're like giving him [ __ ] it's
just like no dude this is what you would
sound like if you were born in 1907 stop
acting like you would be woke signaling
in the roaring 20s you were woke in the
roaring 20s you'd be like put away you'd
be a you would be beyond the what what
would be woke alright well in the 20s
welcome the 20s that's funny you you
would be gone we need to be nice to
these and you'll be using racial slurs
[Laughter]
we need to be nice to these whatever's
and they need to have their own section
of town where they stay away from us but
there should be these these so-and-so
should be allowed to have running water
yeah that would be a liberal and the
really woke ones would be like and you
know what we should even be a little
nice to these so-and-so yeah these new
so-and-so in the next block the next so
it's over yeah you know I was just
reading because I don't read a lot
either I want I read like a lot of
quarter books I get that I get really
jazzed about a book and I read the first
quarter but I was gonna rest getting the
gist yeah all right whatever but I my
brother and I were writing this thing
about him that was set in the like late
1800s kind of this goes common in and I
wanted to get the feel for the language
and so I started reading through on
Walden Pond I started reading which I
had never read and it's like a the row
book oh my god they make you read and I
can't believe I don't think I'd ever
read I didn't remember it anyway what is
it called its called a Walden Pond Wald
Walden Pond I'm Walden yeah that was in
Massachusetts wasn't it yeah I think or
or ham New Hampshire New Hampshire
should I should know this I read a
quarter okay but there's a part in it
then he was like the transcendentalist
you know he was part of that movement
that was like they were a huge
abolitionist and so they were very for
their time they were like the woke guy
that the transcendentalist were like
like em they were the woke guys for
their time and and girls okay and and
fluid and they and they and she's and us
us
to ask you man's I guess that's why
people have you noticed that on
Instagram a lot like this is my favorite
human I love this human have you noticed
people using that language
so you can't get in trouble maybe maybe
but Thoreau said he was talking about
you know how wrong slavery is and like
all of these progressive things and then
he goes but uh I think he started
talking about Irish people and he was
like he started talking [ __ ] about Irish
people I was like except everyone should
be allowed to have these freedom except
of course the Irish to me at the time
that like they that was the the minority
that was not even even the woke people
at the time weren't open to well I don't
know I've never heard of that that Nina
which meant no Irish need apply hmm I
never heard of that so like when they
came over like that's that's what they
they were greeted with I got to read a
little bit of advertised you want to sit
here and watch me read out live the fans
live yeah all right who do we uh we got
a bunch here we got a bunch here me oh
this three here all right what do we got
we got manscaped honey I saw a lot of
manscaped people out there and I'll tell
you they were fierce for the Monday
morning podcast comes manscape if you're
going to the Pride Parade it's a little
late to do this but for next future gay
pride all right when you're going down
wearing a song and a [ __ ] antelope
head product yes number one in men's
below the belt grooming I use it above
the belt two guys whose can who gays
know to do this this is for straight
guys shave your hairy ass yes manscape
offers precision this means it won't
chip you [ __ ] nutbag engineered tools
for manscaping with the right tool for
the job talking points yeah ball bag
your ball bag your ball bag wouldn't it
be nice if it's smooth when you were
younger but still ready to operate look
at me when you're with a full-grown
woman bills staring right at me boy I am
I'll talk about my ball bag right in
front of you evoke evoking the memory
and fear of nicking your ball sack while
manscaping
oh this is what I'm supposed to be doing
but he's like this is like this is like
what's-his-face the guy from streets of
San Francisco when he was in that movie
dog dad well I don't know that
Karl Malden and the guy married the
[ __ ] raven hair chick Michael Douglas
okay okay anyway he was in that bat
movie Kirk Douglas know Michael is with
Karl Malden really in the streets of San
Francisco thought it was stood you never
heard that you never heard the [ __ ]
theme song to that no dude this is
allowed to do this while you're reading
the ads yes oh no cuz this is why people
don't skip over my ads ha this is great
let's see if I could find this it's true
the ads are some of the best parts the
there's this this [ __ ] here and the
companies don't get they don't care they
don't get upset TV tuners did you lose
some advertisers right bill Jefferson
taxi that's not it
I got all these things Monday Night
Football
ah you [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude I'm playing that I got to play that
dude
it's oh yeah dude yeah The Beastie Boys
should have covered it was so quite
themed streets of San Francisco yeah I
could do that while you're reading yeah
you do that Dave look at this it's it
now it's a two-hander is what they call
it in a business it's a two hand here
all right so let's get let's get back to
manscaped here with the transition back
to smooth balls but you can do it I
don't know where I don't know where the
advertising win what does the [ __ ] you
got to be kidding me
it just went away oh so you Lou you lost
them already as an advertiser no I just
it all just went away like I had okay
I'm gonna play it Patrick
streets of San Francisco theme no I need
I need to do this [ __ ] [ __ ] I cannot
even edit this right now people find
this interesting
this way this way to the horns kick in
there you go
the extended version
[Music]
we'd be sitting on our bean bags with
[ __ ] popcorn the streets of San
Francisco in color so I love this [ __ ]
this is like what cult lugar yeah I know
if I can play the whole song I might get
in trouble I might I might owe some
money or something
when we played [ __ ] it three minutes of
that [ __ ] that's cool yeah and it would
just be like Karl Malden was like a
[ __ ] 90 year old white guy and he'd
be chasing down Puerto Ricans and
somehow catching up to him it wasn't
that show there was just so many of
those those cop shows blues and stuff
like Colt Luger he's supposed to be
caught Lugar's on emphasis family sorry
yeah he's supposed to be like a former
movie star yeah
who's like a sex symbol everything and
now it's looking the TV show he's at
that point in his career where now he's
doing TV and back then doing Jan Michael
Vincent
yeah like doing I loved hearing Monday I
think he just died yeah he did he did
not die in a pretty way either oh yeah
one in a [ __ ] dead tree man he was
like [ __ ] losing his legs and [ __ ]
yeah I know he had diabetes yeah I was
bad it was you know I knew him from
because he started doing talked about so
then after you do that TV show like you
were mentioning then you start doing
what I grew up watching during my
formative years which is nice skinemax
movies you'd started I mean like caged
fury
you know like movies like that you know
those places Kennebec you know what they
didn't use Man skate Oh
bring it back bring it back all right
[ __ ] segue they're [ __ ] a [ __ ]
segregated voguing memories of the fear
of nicking your ball sack while
manscaping yet do I need to evoke the
fear I don't know I want to know what
you have anyways yeah you good you guys
like your ball bag do you like your ball
bag being [ __ ] do you like the
contents of yeah yeah you want them to
stay in your balls
use manscape it's the perfect package
2.0 kit that features the lawn mower gee
that sounds like it's for the ladies you
need a weedwacker for the men
2.0 at the skin-safe technology this
trim trimmer won't Nick or snag your
nuts what's worse an Icarus snag oh boy
will snag suggest that it's still in
there I would take the snag because you
get it over with a snag means like so
much your ball bag got in there that it
stopped the Machine exact Nick you took
the loss and you're gonna feel that for
a while and then when the snag you got
us somehow extricate your balls
therefrom yeah and then later on that
night when you're getting a little bit
of action you know and it's still a
fresh cut down there then you got to
worry that you know right what God knows
what just went in there what women have
to hate balls
I need always amazed me when when they
get enough advantages they can take a
couple of balls every that's well it's
also 100% waterproof so you can use it
in the shower you can [ __ ] shave your
balls in the shower
don't use the trimmer you did that when
I was a kid you died and everybody
laughed at you is he like to cuted
himself trying to shave his balls well
you know what they should do with a ball
shaver they should wait they should
somehow find a way to make the balls
cold you know there should be some sort
of air conditioning units so they
shrivel up and then you get that kind of
like elephant skin and then it's easier
boys want to be more wrinkled no no it's
wrinkled is when it's warm and they kind
of hang but but when it's cold and they
can eat it to go back into your body it
gets kind of like tight and more of a
knit like an easy so that's that's the
expression to feel you freeze your balls
off because your balls literally will
pull pull up India yeah yeah yeah see
you went to Vassar so you say rescind
yes sir I thought you meant so you know
about balls so ball yeah balls go yeah
all right don't usage the same trimmer
on your face that you use on your balls
I don't understand that your balls are
cool your balls should be offended your
balls are cleaner than your face your
face is just taking the [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah they're protected by layers of
clothes yeah precision tools I bet those
Arab women have really clean [ __ ]
faces right with they have underwear in
their face precision tools really pay
off for your family jewels your balls
will thank you get 20% off free shipping
and a free travel bag with the code bur
at manscape calm all right we got me
undies
me undies go over to the gay pride
parade do-do-do-do biondi's biondi's did
I mention they were gay running around
in the village why did I say village I
can't run with that whatever too many
[ __ ] sweaty people running trying to
grab some balls and pillage me undies me
honey's got a hole in the butt and make
an easier entrance summer comes with the
number of awesome perks vacations Beach
days and barbecues but the one perk that
outshines outshines them all is summer
themed undies courtesy of you guessed at
me undies me undies you guys should make
a Gay Pride [ __ ] me undies the undies
is the only brand that lets you eat
pineapples while wearing pineapple
undies or watch this or watch the sky
that's how they use the manscaping
they'd see if it can it can [ __ ] cut
a pineapple without damaging any of the
pineapple itself I love a product tester
for that company yeah she got your balls
again we're so sorry
Kiwis would be good to test on oh yeah
that's sort of an eczema yeah or watch
the sky light up on the 4th of July
knowing your undies are doing the same
look out for our new summer themed
prints dropped every day Tuesday me
undies also makes the softest lounge
pants and onesies you've ever felt
finally you can match with your pup with
their new buddy brands available in the
same prints and colors as their undies
this is important stuff if they have
underwear for a dog is that what just
happened me undies has a great offer
from my listeners any first-time
purchasers purchasers when you purchase
me any me undies product you get 15% off
and free shipping that's a big fat duh I
hate that line I'll never read that
again get 15% off a pair of the most
comfortable on these you will ever put
on this is a big fat done for a second I
thought you said that I thought they
came out of your brain I'm really
surprised that must be tough that joke
was sweated on me from the parade on the
way over here to get 15% off your first
pair free shipping at a hundred cents
satisfaction guarantee go to me undies
calm / bird that's Maddy's calm
and lastly but not leastly stamps calm
the US Postal Service is an important
tool for any business stamps.com is the
easiest way to access all the amazing
services of the post office stamps calm
never closes print postage for letters
and packages at your convenience 24/7
print postage for any mail class right
from your own computer
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service right
to your fingertips I literally just said
that by imprint official US postage for
any letter any package any class of mail
using your own computer or printer
stamps.com makes it easy they'll send
you a digital scale that automatically
calculates the exact post egde I use
stamps calm whenever I'm sending out my
posters to the gig when I [ __ ] myself
out afterwards I'm a [ __ ] if I can do
it so can you and right now you too can
enjoy stamps calm the stamps.com service
with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a
digital scale go to stamps comm click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in bur that stamps.com
enter bur all right we're in the
homestretch here you want to do how much
time are we done here with four what are
we up to forty fifty six minutes I can
feel an hour man that's how long I've
been doing this all right damn let's do
uh you don't jealous of your meat what's
the meat company that you put your
advert else what's your boss ah god I
wish they would do that yeah I wish that
again you got to get the heritage breed
pork I know I'm trying to get them to be
a sponsor so we can for free well they
what's the name of your podcast life is
short yeah life is short
guys like Fisher I do with my brother
it's so [ __ ] fun I'll say about that
when you were saying how fun it is to do
stand-up and the difference between
acting you know you've been acting yeah
it's great don't ever don't ever sell
your rights or give to give them this is
your thing you do don't have a [ __ ]
do that I'm doing over the company this
company wondering I know I know I know
if I want to free yourself come over to
come over to [ __ ] all things comedy
we don't poach we don't poach just
saying you own your podcast alright dear
Billy the DILF this is from a female fan
that's a dad I'd like to [ __ ] look at me
yeah yeah I'd like to [ __ ] you that's
cool that's cool every once in a while I
get a little nod I am assumed to be
twenty furo 24-year old lady
a lady lady lady I said lady a' cuz i my
eyes go fast in them i'm able to talk
lady at majora lady from serbian part of
Bosnia and has hers Adobe Nia
oh wow that's Eastern Europe everybody I
am currently studying economics in
Vienna and I am so sad I missed you in
January and one of my favorite gigs I've
ever done I'll definitely be back
because I had to wait for my visa to
approve back home in Bosnia hope you'll
come again sometime I definitely will
I've been waiting to write in for quite
some time because I think I have the
perfect opening greeting because you are
a DILF
this is [ __ ] bizarre I'm already I'm
already saying this is [ __ ] this is
a guy from Transylvania writing this in
you are actually my father's age gross
this is okay I have no father issue at
all out not at all you were wondering
she does protest too much I just think
you're really handsome
who knew that's where after you go to
Eastern Europe I'm actually a good
looking guy good evening my question is
are you going to Wimbledon this year to
support Novak Djokovic have you ever
watched him play yes I've watched him
play at Roland Garros Garros Roland
Garros the French opened to us Americans
he will probably be in the final again
this year or so I hope he has had one of
the best comebacks in the history of
tennis going from an elbow injury to
number one again since last year all the
best to you and your family well you
know something I'm like she brings her
family and through it I'd like to bang
in front of your wife all the best
PS when you were on Conan you said you
were coming to Bosnia as part of your
European tour and you weren't oh oh well
I must have [ __ ] up I think I meant
Boston I thought there would be
something you could chime in on all
right let me do something else here okay
well you know what I was just thinking
about was me I was I was hung up on the
fact that she was born either right
after at the height of that war that
like really intense war yeah I got a
little tense with the genocide and all
that did and you're here she is now it
didn't clinton lob a couple bombs over
there present
get the [ __ ] heat off of them so that
they're [ __ ] animals they're all
animals other than Jimmy Carter but I
like the first George Bush I loved every
time Jimmy Carter's a great guy George
Bush was [ __ ] pilot in World War two
there's nothing not to like other than
that you had an actor you had the boss's
son at a horny jerk-off from Arkansas
what do you know what you've been
getting a lot of letters from women
which is great and I know you're excited
about that but they're the last year you
got the last one was kind of like you
could it was hard to even figure out
what it meant
it was so yeah that happens a lot well
if you listen to me read out loud it's
hard to figure out what I meant so
that's my audience that's what I have no
one to blame but myself right well you
can't [ __ ] on them because they're your
fans
oh they [ __ ] on me all the time nearly
bum balls all right
glad you're enjoying being a dad mine's
five now the only times the only times
in reacted with okay the only times I
reacted with other kids were alright one
my kids mate was blasting my boy in the
face with the super-soakers so I took it
out of his hand and blasted him in the
face till he started crying she's what I
know you shouldn't do that but I
understand Chris Rock I understand and
to to some bigger kids were playing
football next to my toddler toddler but
the toddler playground and they kicked
the ball over the fence so I picked up
the ball and threw it as far as I could
out dude yeah this guy's got issues I
used to play in goal so I knew how to
throw it after they asked where the ball
went they went off looking for it they
never came back love from London peas I
got football he's talking soccer he's
way goal so he did that he did the
[ __ ] uh on our to do it he's little
[ __ ] [ __ ]
they never found the ball then today
okay I deserved it well it's a bit like
what you're dealing with on the
playground with that that's such a funny
story when you caught under your breath
and then his friend was watching stared
at me then they took me was he talking
yeah I know I know that made me laugh so
hard imagine it with a big dumb mustache
as bad
imagining those two little kids it's
probably the first time I heard an adult
call them that wasn't my prouder moment
yeah but what do you do you want to
defend your your little too sweet little
daughter I mean it must be yeah doing I
got to tell you like the craziest thing
about becoming a parent is that day when
you realize you know they're old enough
and you suddenly feel like that
being needed yes [ __ ] crazy yeah and
I don't mean in your to satisfy your own
ego this person needs me it's just like
whoa like like I gotta push I have a
responsibility I have to be here so you
know I hung out with my friends kid not
not like separate from their parents and
I noticed we were doing bits together I
was we were it was felt so good making
this kid laugh yeah and and it started
to advance this thing she would be on
the couch and I was down on the floor
and then she would get off the couch and
I'd start going up on the Cape and was
this back and forth and then she'd go
halfway and I'd go halfway and it was
making her laugh so hard it felt so good
and I and I started to see the evolution
of her sense of humor a little oh yeah
but that must be a thrill to watch her
yes discover comedy now she has she has
a ridiculous ridiculous sense of humor
bed like she gets she gets like in like
a mischievous way if she doesn't do what
we say mm-hmm she thinks it's funny in
it but obvious but she and then she
Olsen can hear tone when I'm being
serious like you know if she doesn't do
something that I wanted to do and I
think it's funny I just go hey and then
she runs away in it's funny path but you
got to be careful with that because you
got to make sure they also know when you
seriously mean something because I think
I'll come on cuz they go out sign they
walk towards the truck and you're like
hey stop and like hahaha yeah you gotta
watch out yeah like I have yeah the
Stephen Stephen King has nothing on a
parent's imagination of a [ __ ]
horrible [ __ ] that you can think let's
read one more and then we'll be done
here all right
Ford verse four by the way thank you so
much for coming on oh this is what a
thrill for that kind of sarcastic but I
know I what a thrill I can tell how
[ __ ] excited you are you but you've
been you've been a little little nervous
yeah yeah sorry
now you've been you've been like you've
been a little like you're definitely
showing the podcast too much respect
no it's deserved all right board verse
Ferrari not to say that you performance
suffered before you get in your actor
head here good alright hey Billy putt
plug when you were talking on your last
podcast about how dominant Ferrari was
at f1 it reminded me that the trailer
for Ford verse Ferrari just came out
which may interest you I heard that's
incredible it stars Matt Damon and
Christian Bale amen and it's about the
story of Ford trying to engineer a car
and find a driver to beat Ferrari at the
1966 LeMans which I know how that ended
would like to know would like to know
how wet this makes you gross thanks and
go [ __ ] yourself I don't even know if
that's still in in theaters but uh
that's a big that's a big [ __ ] baby
boomer super-rich guy car is to buy one
of those for debt Ford GT from the
LeMans I always say I had it as a kid I
had it like at the toy car uh-huh I had
all these guys like Jackie Stewart's elf
car the blue one the Johnny players
special I had all of these these race
cars when I was a kid not knowing who
these people were and then later in my
adult life I got into racing and I went
back through the history I was going
like I had that guy's toy I mean I knew
of Jackie Stewart but anyways that's a
whole nother tangent here and my kid
gets up in like another hour so I got a
wrap all right I got to tell you dude if
I there's no other person I would want
to wade through the gay pride parade at
95 degrees with then you dude I got to
thank you for all your seasons of
absolutely [ __ ] brilliant luck doing
it I [ __ ] love doing it it's just a
fun character I'm you know we should
record more in person because that's I
miss doing that I miss Ben yeah well
never get Sam to get out of the [ __ ]
house that a agoraphobic lunatic that's
[ __ ] an oscar-winning son of a [ __ ]
how about that huh great but I think we
got a couple of Oscar winners at this
point yeah she must have something she's
been nominated I don't know if no golden
globes she's got all that stuff she is
that and also everything she has that
ability everything that she picks is
always amazing yeah and I love Vince's
character on it I know I've been really
enjoying that because I you know when
you record him you don't really get to I
don't always read the
episodes which is embarrassing to admit
yeah read my stuff but I also as a fan
of the show I like waiting for the
episode to come out yeah so fun man
alright well season four should be
coming out uh I don't know probably the
beginning next year they renewed us
pretty quick this year so we cranked him
out actually I got it I got to go home
and [ __ ] edit one of the animatics my
favorite thing oh really
editing yeah I hate it I hate it but uh
but I do it it's a labor of love all
right Justin long everybody has his own
podcast called life is short ah where
can I see it Apple all over what Apple
one wonder II wonder recom wand recom
playin short it's we're gonna go the
Apple music think iTunes itunes okay see
that boy it's like the blind leading the
blind really r41
yeah I never the first time ever he
looks 41 on the Apple thing it's a fruit
they're paired calm the World Wide Web
they're the World Wide Web
alright Justin thank you so much thanks
and good luck to both of us getting them
up out of here oh my god alright buddy
beautiful I'm sorry I was I I feel I
shouldn't have said that
I shouldn't have said that ya know
something and also feeling like